I'm joined now by the chief executive of
the NHS Confederation Matthew Taylor
Matthew Taylor good morning to you
thanks for being with us so look how are
patients going to be affected by the
knock-on effects of the industrial
action
well I think first thing to say is that
the NHS coped as well as can be expected
what happened yesterday and I think
that's a combination of two things first
of all the planning that went into
preparing for this industrial action and
secondly the public made less use of 999
and I think we should thank the public
for for doing that but it does mean that
there will be pent-up demand so we are
expecting a very busy day for emergency
departments today but also yesterday
there were knock-on effects more 111
calls and that um has led to more people
we referred to GP Services out of our
services
um so you know this industrial action uh
has an effect we just about coped
yesterday although there are any immense
strains on the health servers as a whole
but we can't we can't afford to drift
into further industrial action across
the winter yeah are you saying coping uh
just about getting by I mean some are
saying that this is what a collapsed NHS
looks like would you agree
well we know why the NHS is facing the
challenges that it's facing we have 130
000 vacancies and that's part of the
reason why the trade unions are taking
action because of the problems we have
we're recruiting and retaining and
motivating our staff we know we haven't
invested the capital that we need to
invest you know we had the 10 years of
our austerity it meant we went into
covert with 100 000 vacancies with a
crumbling estate so what we've got now
is a big gap between demand and capacity
and even though the Health Service Works
flat out you know we've more or less
eradicated two-year waiters we're making
good progress towards 18 uh getting down
to 18 months so we are making progress
but we've got this gap between demand
and capacity and that's that Gap is
going to take time to close and whilst
we've got that gap between the demand
and the capacity then things are very
intense and they're particularly intense
always in the winter which is why this
is the worst possible time for
industrial action
yeah and that gap between demand and
capacity uh Matthew daily you say that
there's a gap and it can be closed I
mean I do want to can it be closed can
we close the gap between demanding
capacity for the NHS
yes I think we can if we have consistent
funding
and we need the right policies I'll give
you an example there is money that has
now been made available to help get
people out of Hospital into Community
settings give them support at home and
that is very welcome the problem is that
money wasn't announced until
um a few weeks ago and so it's not being
able to get through to the front line
now that money's been promised for the
next three years so hopefully by the
time we get to next winter we'll have in
place mechanisms which mean we have
fewer people unable to leave hospital
because it's the people who are unable
to leave Hospital even though they're
ready to they're medically fit to do
that do so which means that we have no
beds in hospital which means we can't
get people out of emergency departments
which means that emergency departments
can't take people which means ambulance
is stacked up at the front
so all of these issues are connected if
we have consistent funding if if we
address that Workforce issue we've been
calling for years for a Workforce
strategy we've been promised one next
year so there are signs of Hope looking
forward but we're paying the price now
for those 10 years of austerity for the
covid backlog for not addressing these
issues so this winter is going to this
is going to be incredibly tough there's
nothing we can do about that but the
industrial action adds to what is
already a challenging situation which is
why you know on behalf of leaders in the
NHS you know I repeat the call to the
government to re-enter negotiations in
good faith for the trade unions to
re-enter negotiations and to try to find
a way of avoiding further industrial
action across the winter now the
government say they're not going to talk
about pay it at this point I I do Wonder
um I said I'd like to get your opinion
on the the rcns and their demand for uh
five percent above RPI
um pay increases about 19 right now do
you think it would be better
strategically for the RCN to perhaps
come in with a lower paid demand that
might well get negotiations going
well look we all know how negotiations
work people have starting positions and
everyone knows that the outcome is is
somewhere between the starting positions
of both sides the problem we've got now
is that
because the government refuses to
negotiate about pay and because the
trade unions refuse to enter
negotiations if pay is not on the table
we've got an impasse and it's going to
require leadership it's going to require
creativity to to get out of that and
pass somebody needs to move I think
probably
if the government was able to talk to
say we'll talk about pay in some way or
other that could bring the trade unions
to the table
so look I understand where the trade
unions are coming from I understand the
concerns that their work is about pay I
understand this isn't just about pay
from their perspective either I also
understand the challenges facing
government on public spending on a range
of industrial disputes they're facing
but we need leadership we need
imagination because the Health Service
cannot deal with a winter of industrial
action without there being severe
effects on patient well-being
and last thought from here Matthew
Taylor what is your advice to people who
needs to use the NHS in the next few
days and weeks
so we're grateful to the public for the
way in which they reduce demand for 999
yesterday but there will be pent-up
demand today but the really important
message is if you have a healthy need
the Health Service is there for you
primary care has not been affected by
the industrial action if you have an
emergency call 999.
because you know one of the reasons we
are where we are is because during covid
people didn't come forward that's why
we've got millions of people on waiting
for this why many leaders I speak to say
that the people come into emergency
departments have more complex and
difficult challenges so it's actually
not in anyone's interests for people not
to come forward the Health Service is
under immense pressure but it is there
for you if you have concerns about your
health contact your GP if you have an
emergency contact 999 if you're not sure
ring one one one